modus in berlin hochbetrieb in der
großküche 149 fraktionen und im zweiten
beratung heute 118 auf 106 8 das startup
green co sieht eine marktlücke gesundes
essen für gestresste großstädter
ihr könnt ihr auf jeden fall schon dahin
das ist immer schneller alles kommen
muss das richtig war ist da ins intranet
man das auf knopfdruck phase an seine
bedürfnisse gedeckte sehen will und
besonders in der mittagspause ist das
sehr wichtig war den meisten leuten zu
feiern
zwei von drei bundesbürgern legen wert
auf gesunde ernährung das sagen sie
zumindest in umfragen
im supermarkt bestätigt sich der trend
besonders beliebt hier flüssige snacks
für die mittagspause
also die leute wenn mehr bedacht auf
frische und auf bioprodukte zumindest
die konventionellen fertigprodukte die
konservierungsstoffe und auch ich bin
nicht mehr so gefragt wie die sachen die
wirklich prüfen
der markt für fertigprodukte stagniert
ein problem für die hersteller markt
über net lebt jetzt frau forschung die
idee hätten soll künftig präventiv gegen
krankheiten wirken weder etwas ihm
gewinner macht je nach genetischer
disposition und vorerkrankungen die
nestlé deutschland schätzen sie den
megatrend maßgeschneiderte ernährung es
ist nicht mehr die gleiche ernährung für
alle sondern linie individualisiert
abhängig von meinem körper vor euch
vielleicht mehr die unabhängig vom alter
mann oder frau mit den viele parameter
dabei
ernährungsberatung digitales auf das
könnte bald zum geschäft der
lebensmittel hersteller gehören dann
ließe sich übrigens genau feststehen wer
ist tatsächlich wahr
noch gibt es dann nur ungefähre
durchschnittswerte zum beispiel an
fleisch im durchschnitt hat jeder
bundesbürger rund 60 kilogramm im jahr
dort gibt eine gegenbewegung immer mehr
vegetarier entenfleisch und jeder
hundertste bundesbürger nutzt gar keine
produkte mehr zu zahlen bekannt ist auch
am wachsen in den letzten jahren
natürlich momentan ist es nennen wer
großer bogen der auch für aufmerksamkeit
bekommt wird vielleicht wieder müssen
abwarten aber zukünftig auf die
langfristige entwicklung denken wir dass
vegan auf jeden fall noch größerer trend
wird im gegenteil sagt der fleischer
gleich nebenan vegetarier und veganer
seien nur eine kleine minderheit und
sein produkt auch in zukunft noch
gefragt
unsere kundschaft ist genauso wie vorher
das fleisch wird beim fleischverzehr
konzentriert etwas weniger aber dafür
qualität beim lieferdienst green blue
sind noch ein paar salate von morgen
bricht doch wegschmeißen will man nicht
die lösung ist digital
das fahrrad rescue vertreibt essen das
übrig blieb europaweit wurden so im
letzten jahrhundert 1000 portionen vor
dem mülleimer gerettet rapidler online
plattform wo man sozusagen
überschüssiges öffnung von restaurant
und café vergünstigt bestehen kann als
privatperson und es geht darum dass er
einfach keine lebensmittel mehr
verschwenden insgesamt sucht wenn man
familie vom kilogramm menge sich das
angucken würde der europaweite wir bei
30.000 kilogramm essen oder gleich nur
nach bedarf produzieren lassen
verletzung und trio lebensmittel aus dem
drucker menge farbe und form nach wunsch
[Musik]